[Musique]
il y a 5 ans Léa Saint-Louis a choisi
d'ouvrir son commerce en plein coeur de
rouanne-noranda aujourd'hui elle se
range aux côtés des dizaines
d'entrepreneurs locaux qui soutiennent
que la crise de la qualité de l'air nuit
à leurs efforts de développement de
recrutement et de rétention de la main
d'oeuvre si plus d'une centaine ont
accepté de signer le mémoire déposer
jeudi seulement 66 d'entre eux ont
accepté de le faire publiquement ceux
qui préférait rester anonyme disent le
faire par crainte dans subir les
contrecoups non je vais
ais pas comme disait si ça a lieu à être
négatif pour moi rendu là je regarderai
ce que je ferai mais je pense que c'est
la santé et l'environnement trop
important pour avoir peur
d'en parler Patrick Raoul qui est
propriétaire d'une boutique spécialisée
dans la vente de produits électroniques
à quant à lui hésité à s'afficher
publiquement en désaccord avec le plan
proposé par la fonderie il espère
toutefois que la voix commune du groupe
permettra de revoir l'argument
économique dans ce dossier il y a quand
même un autre volet économique de la
ville qui est aussi inquiet si on laisse
aller ça de cette façon là par rapport à
l'image de la ville par rapport à
l'attraction de nouveaux employés par
rapport à la rétention des des personnes
qui vont vouloir partir bien qu'elle dit
comprendre la position du regroupement
la Chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
Rouyn-Noranda réaffirme plutôt sa
confiance envers l'entreprise dans son
propre mémoire la fonderie
majeur on exclut la fermeture dans notre
dans après avoir sondé nos membres nos
membres nous disent il faut pas fermer
d'en fonderie c'est ça une importance
stratégique les consultations publiques
sont maintenant terminées dans ce
dossier mais plusieurs citoyens
craignent que leur message ne soient
perdus puisque le sous-ministre à
l'environnement marque Croteau qui était
d'ailleurs à Rouyn-Noranda cette semaine
a été remplacé ici Guillaume Renaud
Radio-Canada Roanne